ukraine crisis the power of language in
the interview the novelist andre kurkov
we are at the international literature
festival in berlin where you are one of
the participants andrei korkov you are a
ukrainian writer from kiev you speak or
at least you understand 11 languages
welcome to the interview on dw
interview
i speak six the others are gone because
i didn't use them
i suggest
there are more translations of works by
you than by any other ukrainian writer
your latest work is ukraine diaries
dispatches from kiev
it's about the maidan revolution
but it has not yet appeared in ukrainian
or russian
is it just for exports
it was written instead of another book
that i had started in october it was
going to be a collection of essays for
foreign readers about ukraine the way it
was and the way it is today
about the differences between russian
and ukrainian history and about the
differences between the mentalities and
politics of the two countries
but then after the protests began on
november the 21st i realized i couldn't
write a relaxed book in these tense
times
so i called my publishers in austria and
offered them ukraine diaries instead
entries from november the 21st to april
the 24th the events of each day without
regard to what would happen the
following day
ukraine diaries is something of an
exception in your works
it's about current events of interest to
readers in the west right now
your other works including bestsellers
such as death and the penguin are
intended more for ukrainian readers how
do you explain your popularity in the
west and in germany
it's probably because the stories i tell
are gripping and in some way universal
foreign readers can empathize with my
ukrainian protagonists
perhaps the mix of black humor and
absurdist irony in all my books
also has some appeal
you were born in leningrad in russia and
moved to kiev where you still live you
write in russian so are you a russian
writer or a ukrainian writer
ukraine i'm a ukrainian writer of
russian origin who writes in the
language of his heritage the argument
about what i really am has been going on
for 20 years i fight for the rights of
ukrainian authors who write in russian
who identify with ukraine and ukrainian
literature not all ukrainian
intellectuals think like me so the
argument will continue
that means some people think it's not
politically correct to write in russian
in ukraine
russian is the first and greatest victim
of the political situation and the
conflict with russia
nonetheless i write mainly in russian
just a few essays are in ukrainian and
english
russian is spoken more quietly now
because for the very many russian
speakers in ukraine 12 million ethnic
russians and probably 10 to 12 million
ukrainians their mother tongue has
become the language of the aggressor
that's why they now speak more softly
but all your books have been translated
into ukrainian
all the new ones are published
simultaneously in russian and ukrainian
though my children's books are only in
ukrainian none of my books have been
published in russia since 2008. i don't
exist there and in ukraine readers
prefer children's books in ukrainian
you described russian as the language of
the aggressor so what does that mean for
the future as you said it's the mother
tongue of 12 million
these 12 million feel ukrainian
ukrainian citizens who do not need putin
to protect them because they speak
russian
they don't face any bans and don't have
any problem speaking russian there never
was any such problem
politicians invented the language
problem to divide the electorate instead
of discussing ways to develop the
country one faction said it wanted
russian declared an official language
while the other faction promised to
prevent russian ever becoming an
official language
but one of the first things the new
government tried to do was impose
restrictions on russian
many observers considered misguided
it was not an attempt to restrict the
use of russian
and it wasn't the government it was a
member of yushchenko's party called
svyatoslav kirilenko
during a session of parliament he called
for the repeal of a law that yanukovych
had pushed through in 2012 that gave the
languages of minorities official status
as regional languages
in reality the repeal of the law would
have changed nothing and president
poroshenko never signed the repeal so
it's not on the books
this law never used to play any role
it's now become important
de facto they use russian as the
official language in eastern ukraine
both in official communication in the
courts and in other areas as well
there was very little ukrainian spoken
there
the law simply gave russian an official
status in the east of the country
but how do you explain the fact that the
works of gogol for example a great
ukrainian writer who wrote in russian
are taught as foreign literature in
schools
after the transition of power in 1991 or
rather after the country changed its
name without a transition of power the
government decided on a special gesture
it created jobs for ukrainian
nationalists in the areas of information
culture and education but not the
economy
at the same time russian-speaking
culture in ukraine has never been
investigated for example is bulgarkov a
ukrainian or a russian writer
it's a question of
gogol's
identity
as a writer was russian though he
enriched literally high russian with
thousands of ukrainian words
you could say he introduced ukrainian
into russian but i think the
relationship to russian-speaking writers
in ukraine will change
it will become more civilized
i think we'll develop a more inclusive
and less exclusive culture
there's still a powerful group of
intellectuals who think that ukrainian
culture means ethnic ukrainian culture
but there's an even more powerful group
that believes we are a multi-national
state and whatever is created here
whether by hungarians greeks bulgarians
ethnic russians or jews it's all part of
ukrainian culture
this contest this argument will continue
but in the end the more civilized
inclusive position will prevail we
professionally
what role does literature play for you
in these unsettled times
and what role does analysis the
observation of trends in society
since november i've hardly touched
literature i've been busy with essays
and my diary
i've written almost 100 articles about
the situation in donbass crimea and kiev
i write about politics and am more of a
social activist than a writer at the
moment
so as an engineer of the human soul
or as an engineer of a civil society
how do you evaluate current trends in
ukrainian society
are we seeing the birth of a nation
the transformation of a nation
or
we're seeing the recovery after a
collapse caused by politicians
ten years ago it was correct to say that
one part of ukraine was pro-russian and
another pro-ukrainian
but now thanks to yanukovych and putin
the country has come together
all the regions apart from donbass and
crimea have become pro-european
they've all come to appreciate the
importance of a united country
at the same time we're also seeing a
transformation a tolerant and peaceful
society has been radicalized i think
we'll see a permanent state of war and
conflict in the east
i don't wish to repeat russian
propaganda about what it calls a fascist
hunter
but what about the disturbing tendencies
in western ukraine such as the
nationalist rights sector party
if a hunter were in power in kiev it
would have simply bombed donbass to
smithereens generals would be in power
tanks
ukrainian politicians have always been
and still
ukraine is moving from an ambivalent
political balancing act between east and
west
to a more decisive form of government
and that will probably lead to a
crackdown on corruption at least i very
much hope so
at the same time i think it's very
important for ukrainians to remain
tolerant towards people with different
backgrounds
i've been arguing with the nationalists
for more than two decades we respect
each other we accept our differences and
we don't hurl abuse at each other i hope
all other ukrainians who disagree about
things will use their tongues and not
their muscles
on tuesday an association agreement
between ukraine and the european union
was ratified
but a central element a full customs
union will be implemented later what do
you think about that
is
i was a bit surprised that it's a
victory seized from europe and not
ukraine this probably weakens poroshenko
on the other hand it all depends on what
further steps ukraine and europe take
some european parliamentarians are
saying that the decision to postpone the
customs union is not final and could be
soon changed or amended
thank you